Jacques Payet, hello.
Hello.
Thank you for welcoming me here today.
Thanks for coming and thanks for the opportunity.
So to begin,
I would like to know where and how you
started your martial arts practice.
Since I was a kid, I've always been drawn to martial arts.
I think it's the influence of Bruce Lee.
But as I was on La Réunion Island, there were only a few judo practitioners, and it was quite far
so it was practically impossible to find a teacher.
So I had to wait for my studies in Lyon.
After I left La Réunion, I spent maybe 4 or 5 years in Lyon
and from that point I started right away.
I started with kung fu, then I
did a little shotokan karate,
and then I started ju jutsu.
This is where one day, I saw an 8mm film of Shioda Gozo,
a little man who threw people much larger than him
while laughing.
And I thought that it looked like magic and that I'd love to go see this if that was really it.
That's how at age 22, without knowing anything about Japan,
without knowing anyone there,
I decided in all my youth, out of pure madness,
to come to Japan and meet Shioda Sensei.
You hadn't practiced aikido in France?
No.
Besides, I had a rather negative image of aikido,
it was too weak,
it wasn't manly enough.
I especially wanted to do ju jutsu, there is a lot of virility in there,
and I saw aikido as too soft.
Even as I saw that film in Japanese,
I didn't know it was aikido, I thought it was ju jutsu.
So I came here looking for: “Shioda Gozo, professor of ju jutsu. "
So obviously everyone is surprised.
And after that I understood of course that it was aikido, and that it was Yoshinkan.
So I think that if Shioda Sensei had done karate or something,
today I would have practiced his discipline.
OK. When I looked at your biography,
I was amazed that you went straight to Shioda Sensei, when anyone would have said:
“Well, Shioda Sensei is very good, he does aikido, I'm going to do aikido. "
That's right.
And even when you got to Tokyo, there were heaps of places where you could have done aikido, but you went straight away ...
No, I came for Shioda Sensei,
and so I really went through the small door.
I guess by "the small door", you mean, without any introduction...
Right, nothing at all.
And besides that, it was in 1980, so there was no internet, there was nothing,
and since I spoke very little English, I had no information.
I just had that name, so I came to Tokyo and then...
When I was in Lyon I had made
acquaintance with Japanese student and we had become friends,
so when I arrived, I called her and I said:
"You have to help me find this teacher, he does ju jutsu, we have to find him."
And so it was her who assisted me,
we visited almost all of the dojos in Tokyo,
and then finally we went to Omiya to a koryu dojo,
and the professor there told us:
“I know Shioda Sensei, his dojo is in Koganei. "
Then we looked in the phone book,
we called, and that's how I joined the dojo.
Considering the time, it was probably very different from today.
How was your arrival there?
It was quite chaotic.
I had very little financial means.
I had very little savings so I posted an ad.
I was at the University of Tokyo in the French literature department
and I put an ad in French:
"Young student would like to share accommodation with a Japanese".
I got an answer two days later I believe,
but it was quite far, in Saitama.
I shared the apartment with him.
Around 2:00 p.m., I took a two-hour journey by train,
I was going to Koganei and I was doing the beginner classes from 4 to 8 p.m.
So I was doing 3 hours and then I was going home at night.
After a month, my savings were gone,
and so on the last day i said goodbye to everyone.
I went to the dojo to say that I was really sorry, but that I had to leave because I had no more money.
By chance, in the parking lot,
there was the son of Shioda Gozo,
who intended to go to England to teach,
so he was looking for a foreigner to talk to in English,
so he was very excited to speak with a French person.
The two of us did not master the language well, but with a few words we could understand each other,
and so I explained my situation and he said to me:
"Well, today must be your lucky day because my father is here, so if
you want I can introduce you. "
I told him that I had come to Japan precisely to meet his father
but that after a month there, I had not even seen him,
so it would be a shame to have done this whole trip and leave without having seen him.
So he said to me, “OK, no problem” and he took me straight to Shioda Gozo's office, and he explained my situation to him.
After a while, Shioda, who was very small, stood up,
he looked at me right in the eyes and said:
"Is it true that you came on purpose to do
of Aikido and that you would like to stay? "
I told him of course, and he told me:
"OK, if you're courageous, if you can get up early in the morning, do all the chores"
"and in addition, if you can do 6 hours of lessons per day, then you are welcome to stay in the dojo, you have nothing to pay"
"or very little, just for amenities, water, electricity, stuff like that."
"If you're interested you can stay 3 months, and if I think you deserve it we'll see after that. "
I was amazed, I thanked him and said that I accepted immediately.
That's how all of a sudden, my life changed completely.
The next day I moved into the dojo.
This is something I heard from one of my teachers in Daito-ryu,
who trained  at the Yoshinkan for a while in the 1960s.
When I asked him if he had taken a lot of lessons with Shioda Sensei, he said:
“No, he was too important already, we couldn't take lessons with him just like that. "
Did he teach regularly, or were there private lessons?
My first entry into Yoshinkan was, I believe, October 1, 1981.
At that time, he was doing regular classes in the evening, I think it was Tuesday evening for an hour,
and Friday, or something like that.
Otherwise he only did black belt courses, or special courses,
maybe twice a week,
and the rest of the classes were done by his instructors.
He just walked around.
For example, I did not take really ukemi for him until...
You had to be at least shodan, before that, you couldn't take ukemi for him.
He didn't speak to me at all for a year.
If he saw anything that I was doing wrong, he would go to the teachers and ask them to correct me.
There was no direct contact.
So I had to wait for when I became uchi deshi, when I took care of him.
I can't say that I could talk to him freely then, but there was some communication,
and I took ukemi for him.
There is debate, even in Japan, about the current meaning of the term uchi deshi.
In this case, there was a direct relationship, you were uchi deshi of Shioda Gozo,
not just a resident student at the Yoshinkan.
That's right.
I think I was lucky because I was included in this small uchi deshi group,
in the sense that a lot of training was done outside of the tatami.
So it was really still the traditional teaching.
What shocked me was that there was the corridor,
there was the office where all the instructors and deshi were,
there was Shioda Sensei's office next door,
and there were two doors, one here, and a one here.
And so the training was to feel when Shioda Sensei was going to come out of his office.
But since there were 2 doors, we didn't know from which one.
The training was to guess...
It depends, maybe we were chatting or drinking,
and immediately, with the sound of the door opening,
we knew immediately which door it was and we started to open the bathroom door, to present...
There was a sense of timing and not thinking,
that the body react automatically.
And that was the teaching of uchi deshi.
There was all this non-verbal aspect that was there and that was becoming almost automatic.
And the body was moving on its own, practically.
It was not conscious but it brought me a lot.
After a while, it became an extraordinary asset that I used in the technique on the tatami.
Then, it's the same for the bath, for example.
It's really bathing, but it's so Japanese,
in the sense that there are no words,
it is communication by osmosis.
You have to be there at the right time.
You can't hesitate, you have to be there.
You have to learn from heart to heart, or body to heart, it's a truly unique teaching,
and I think that's what maybe is missing today.
Without it, I think my outlook on Aikido would have been completely different.
On this subject of the ishin-denshin relatiosbhip...
Right, that's what it is.
... or uchi deshi,
the last person I spoke to who experienced this, other than you,
it was in the completely different of rakugo [storytelling].
It was Katsura Sunshine, who lived with his master exactly in that way.
The question we asked ourselves is that indeed, if we want to learn an art thoroughly,
it's quite difficult in the Japanese system to do it differently from that,
and it is not accessible to everyone, necessarily, and by design.
Is this system it still continuing or is it in decline?
I personally think it's in decline.
Because not too long ago I was at a sushi place,
and the guy told me that now, to open a sushi store,
you just have to go and take lessons in a school for a year or two, and then you get a qualification.
And so it's no longer necessary to be an uchi deshi,
to clean for a year or two before you can touch the knife and do the thing...
Everything is done in a modern way.
I even see it in the Yoshinkan, the system no longer exists.
I don't know in other arts, how is it's going, but I think it is in decline.
And I also think that young Japanese people are not at all interested anymore.
I don't think they intend to spend 4 or 5 years just staring or cleaning,
they immediately want to take action and to learn.
I see. Without having been to such an extent of close long-term relationship with my own Daito-ryu teacher,
it is true that I can't see how certain things, certain teachings that I received, could have passed otherwise.
Right.
Without even being able to explain it, actually.
Exactly, right.
Because I remember things, for example, something mundane,
is that for example, Shioda called us to bring him a nail clipper.
So we brought him a nail clipper,
and then we looked, we waited for him to cut his nails, and then, as if by chance, he said to us:
“Here, what I have here, it's so hard that it's difficult for me to cut my nails. "
So it was a way for him to explain that this is where you have to put your balance...
Lean on...
Put on the weight on, lean on,
and so if we happened to have something elsewhere, that meant we did it wrong.
It is an indirect way of teaching
but if it hadn't been for that opportunity, I wouldn't have known that it was the important point,
because nobody would have said it.
So there are a lot of times like that where you have to be there right now,
otherwise, you won't know.
And the meaning does not necessarily reveal itself immediately...
That's right.
I imagine that you are thinking about things...
Yes, later: “There you go, that's what he meant there."
That I think is something I would like to pass on to my students but it is difficult.
And the system is dying little by little for lack of will
from the students to invest themselves in this type of long-term relationship,
and in particular if there are faster parallel ways, of course,
which we can see a lot anyway
- maybe less so in japan -
but in any case in the rest of the world,
a professionalization of aikido...
There you have it.
and so to be competitive, you have to do seminars, you have to get grades,
and who has time to spend 10 years, completely unknown, in the shadows?
Yes.
It's a shame but maybe it's the time that wants it.
How do you manage to overcome this pedagogical lack in your own teaching?
That's why I wanted to create a little more specialized classes,
and therefore I set up the kenshusei,
with the condition of living in community.
We have a house and the kenshusei are forced to stay for a year
and live together.
So it's not a hotel, they have to really take care of it like it's a dojo.
And besides, I try to keep
- well it doesn't go as far as an uchi deshi -
but I still try to keep what was important to me,
respect, attitude,
towards seniors.
To surpass oneself, of course physically, but also mentally.
I try to do the whole lot, but it gets harder and harder,
because for young people today, It's difficult, they can't stand it.
I think 2 years ago, 2 young people in their twenties,
they didn't last a week, after a week ...
They were mostly in shock...
They'd never seen that so...
There is certainly an image problem with this,
because I regularly receive emails asking me:
"I really want to become an uchi deshi, where can I be an uchi deshi?"
And I responde: "Do you understand what it is?"
Right.
"Are you ready to give up everything, without really any resources."
Because it's an almost total sacrifice,
it's practically becoming someone's slave.
That's it, and without guarantees...
And without guarantees.
It's not like a university degree where it ensures you an income afterwards...
Right, there is really no guarantees.
To get back to the uchi deshi group of the time,
how many people are we talking about,
and were there already foreigners?
Yes when I arrived there was a Frenchman, Muguruza Jacques, who also stayed for five years
and I believe that before him there was someone from New Zealand who stayed for a year.
And before that I think there was a Korean.
But that's about all.
Muguruza left after a year and so I was alone, I was the only foreigner.
OK.
And de facto, once you enter the uchi deshi system,
after a certain period of time are you given teaching responsibilities in the structure?
Yes, because when I got here
so I started at 1980...
in 1981, i became uchi deshi,
and therefore in 1982 -83,
as there were starting to be more foreigners coming to Japan to train at the dojo,
they gave me the...
- I think it's also because they didn't want to... it was easier for me to take care of... -
So my role was to teach beginners and especially foreigners
and after a while,
it was foreigners and Japanese at the same time,
so I took care of beginners like that.
So I was an assistant instructor and then later I became an instructor.
But I imagine there are also other systems of instructors in place, outside of the
uchi deshi program itself?
When I was in Yoshinkan, no, you had to be uchi deshi.
It was done internally.
There were no people from outside who could become uchi deshi.
An obvious difference compared to the functioning of the Aikikai, which I know a little better,
is that there have been foreigners in the teaching staff of the Yoshinkan for a lone time.
Yes.
And it's still not the case at the Aikikai.
Do you know how it came to be and what was the idea behind it?
I think it all comes from the relationship with Shioda Sensei.
I think Shioda Sensei...
I don't remember his name, but there was an Englishman who was a student in the 1950s, at the beginning.
And he was very close to Shioda Sensei,
and since he was well off, I believe when he returned to England he gave him his house.
So the house where Shioda Sensei lived until his death,
belonged to one of his students, he gave it to him, it was like that,
because he respected him, and Shioda, I think that it influenced him a lot.
Since that, there has always been a good relationship,
he was very open-minded.
The uchi deshi who were there, whether it was the New Zealander or the Frenchman Jacques Muguruza,
they really loved aikido, they had done their best, so i think he had some respect for that.
So he was open that's why, I think.
That's what made the difference I guess.
Once these uchi deshi got home, what happened?
Was there still some kind of continuous contact with the Yoshinkan?
I'm thinking for example of the term of curriculum or exam criteria,
things like that, or did everyone do their own thing?
No, it was still ...
- it's a little different since they created the Yoshinkan International there, -
but before it was only a direct line, it was Shioda Sensei, there was only one curriculum,
and all the deshi followed that to the letter.
So initially there were very few branches, really.
The first one was one of the oldest uchi deshi, Kushida Sensei,
in 1973, I believe, he went to Michigan in the United States,
and it is he who really developed the Yoshinkan in the United States.
And so there was the shibucho,
and it is the shibucho that recommended the students directly to Japan,
so there was a system of trust.
They really followed the Hombu curriculum, until almost 1990,
where they setup the International Yoshinkan Federation.
From that time, everyone did a little bit as they wanted,
so we lost a bit of this very strong relationship between the Hombu and the foreigners.